cette équipe ont embarqué le suspense
aujourd'hui à faire qu'on va réagir des
gens qui réagissent à ma vidéo dans
lesquels parfois j'ai réagi à d'autres
trucs incroyables je me suis toujours
demandé la gueule que font les gens ont
leurs réactions même quand il regarde
une de mes vidéos j'ai pu observer des
fois des prochains mois qui voulaient
voir la meilleure vidéo et qu'il a
regardé devant moi parce qu'ils
présentent les situations la plume et
les antes de la planète pour youtube
mais ses proches donc c'est différent
aujourd'hui je vais voir votre visage à
vous quelle gueule vous faites quand
vous regardez le 2 mai vidéo la vidéo a
déjà sa soixante mille vue à date de
plus d'un mois ce que j'ai toujours
alors mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que
je n'ai pas vu parce que je me réserve
la possibilité de faire cette vidéo là
si j'en avais envie et aujourd'hui j'en
ai envie c'est incroyable j'ai prévu
c'est allez c'est parti
[Musique]
ok en charge du retour sur un petit jeu
qui s'appelle picot nos colis on a une
lycéenne un modèle photo au filet on est
modèle photo dans la vie philippe marine
19 ans étudiante chams 17 ans lycéen
juni 19 ans étudiante en tête en nombre
de merde et je sentais très immature ou
en franchement c'est trop rien j'ai
peut-être attend quoi
j'ai peut-être un humour de merde et je
suis peut-être très immature j'ai
peut-être un d'humour de merde je suis
peut-être esi battures alors s'il ya
bien deux mots qui représente la chaîne
c'est cela bien joué aujourd'hui nous
allons mettre à l'épreuve notre capacité
à être ou pas mal à l'aise devant une
situation
annoncé au jeu réagi à des gens qui
réagissent à voyager réagi quoi ça pas
d'audience de montrer ça dans le sens
c'est pas une vidéo que j'ai fait de
toute pièce moi je reviens juste
d'autres vidéos comme actuellement
derrière pour conséquence que pareils
moments ici veulent pas dire ça tu vas
faire tous tes potes la cu trajet non le
malaise est palpable dans la pièce et
une leur sang alors c'est encore pierre
je me sens je me sens mal pour lui en
fait
douzy super permettre là ils réagissent
pas mes vidéos et réagissent
un show qui fait une blague d'un dîner
presque parfait ça mauvais choix de
vidéos là alors on est bien là on est
bien vous voyez ce génie qui sort de sa
lampe et qui sourit à tous les gens qui
vont sur son [ __ ] de sites web ou à le
faire redescendre sur terre un peu parce
que là et non pas lui
akinator ça je devrais jouer à ça quand
j'étais petit ah bah oui oui monsieur
y'avait sayad hibou ou connais bien trop
c'est trop cool c'est marrant en fait si
jamais compris comment ça marche
alors c'est très simple c'est un arbre
de possibilités si tu réponds à une
question ça va tourner vers d'autres
questions et à recherches s'affine au
fur et à mesure que tu répond à des
questions jusqu'à tournoi des questions
hyper précise par exemple youtube heures
at il un chat qui s'appelle john bost
voilages aidé par la société akinator
pour parler de lui aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour une petite population de
jeux gratuits cros tout de suite avec
boxe mike catt cette vidéo est
totalement avec attend c'est abusé je la
regarde pas aux cartes soit faire des
affaires du modèle photo ensemble
apprends moi c'est encore un enfant ah
oui il avait toujours pas une fois viril
j'ai donc maintenant une voix virile
elle l'a dit les gars vous avez que je
prends une grosse voix inconsciemment
comme si je voulais vous prouvez le
voile assez facilement constatable les
progrès en matière de virilité sur la
chaîne youtube sont présents étaient
beaucoup beaucoup trop d'énergie toit en
fait et c'est après qu'il ait commencé à
se calmer un peu plus que j'ai commencé
à regarder vraiment cette vidéo parce
que il y avait de l'humour mais il y
avait qu un petit coup ne peut plus
arriver alors que là c'était pressenti
pour un petit jeune de 17 ans a utilisé
des vidéos et qui essaie de mettre toute
l'énergie qu'il avait pour pourrait y
faire c'est exactement ça en fait c'est
juste lié au fait que avant je sais pas
trop comment faire marrer tous et du
coup il fallait en faire des caisses des
tonnes dans les vidéos et ne plus être
soi-même pour faire marrer alors que
maintenant bah quoi un truc me fait
chier ça soit vous vous voyez que ça me
fait chier j'ai eu moins de vent - truc
mais du coup c'est beaucoup plus
naturelle et spontanée alors qu'un vrai
c'était d'avancer un peu relou mais moi
non j'aime bien faire des vidéos où on
est beaucoup plus posé il ya quand même
de l'humour mais on est quand même plus
nous-mêmes quoi dans la vraie vie mais
quand tu vas faire tes courses tu vas
pas être appelé à tapie avait perçu et
assure ça me fait chier c'est vrai
qu'avant cette europe beaucoup plus
comme ça je suis content de voir en fait
bas une personne qui fait partie de ce
groupe qui regardaient pas du tout les
vidéos avant et qui s'est mis à les
regarder et qui maintenant les
spectateurs de la chaîne youtube mc ça
me fait super plaisir voilà je suis
content
là je suis très content
par jeu d'horreur soit 16 jours d'être à
la hauteur et du coup tu regardes des
gens jouer à ce jeu comme ça tu as moins
peur sur ce nouveau format qu'il a créé
un peu plus tard il est plus posé et
quand même il a quand même son humour
mais il est plus posé
[ __ ] mais et ump choi les modèles
photo ll les dérives il me fait que des
compliments mais viens viens travers
cette porte bien aujourd'hui passager
attend jean populaire dans le secret la
[ __ ] vincent j et ouais surprise bande
de [ __ ] sais pas si c'est la bonne a
pris les rênes
allez on est là chapeau il sort des
remarques monga personnes abusées rap
contenders version cheap
[ __ ] c'est nul c'est pas parce qu on
laisse nos étiquettes sur les fringues
on est on est on va les rendre peut-être
c'est un peu long je pense que s'ils
l'avaient fait sur eux de trois
personnes maxi se serait passé mais je
suis enfin honda ok je m'en fous je m'en
fous pourquoi pas ce moyen modesto qui
veut m'empêcher ok pas toi qu'est ce qui
le caractérise plus selon toi pense que
c est l'humour parce que du coup il
prend vachement tout même lui même il se
rend au second degré un ministre est
sûrs de fragile on s'est vraiment pas se
le cacher moi je pense que c'est le fait
qu'ils soient très humain va sur
l'énergie sont sa diversité et
je pense aussi sa façon de voir toujours
le côté positif des choses et la
persévérance surtout philippe j'aimerais
te dire aujourd'hui j'apprécie beaucoup
tout ce que tu dis en verbe c'est
touchant tu es je t'invite donc si tu
sais assez loin des loges alors là j'ai
toujours pas trop su comment réagir aux
gens qui font des compliments en vrai à
part dire merci et à geneva merci vous
êtes vous êtes très touchant ou alors ce
que vous dites c'est hyper touchant ou
alors j'aimerais vous touchez non-jeu
qualité des voitures préférées
alors qu'est ce qui vous fait rire dans
les vidéos de squeeze j'aimerais
manquant dans ces vidéos il n'y a pas
que lui puisqu il est pas drôle en fait
du coup j'ai vraiment tout ce qui est
drôle et qui met dans sa vidéo mais qui
vient pas de lui cette ville j'adore
quand il fait des termes plaies sur tout
en jeu en entier est comme ça tu suis
les épisodes tu as envie de savoir la
suite the last guardian aux aveux plus
d'avoir quelqu'un aussi dire sapiteur
pas ce qui m'intéresse c'est quand même
vous êtes moins nombreux quand même à
aimer les séries comme ça sur un jeu
vidéo surtout quand le jeu est très
poétique et tout exprès du tout drôle ou
de l'horreur ça fait plaisir d'entendre
ça c'est fou que penses tu de son humour
c'est une bonne humeur un peu beau par
moments mais c'est comme ça que je pense
que ces failles seront vachement from
second degré ne se prend pas la tête et
c'est ça qui est drôle
après il ya des blagues lourdes cette
promesse est des fois c'est tellement
pourri et tu vilaine doigts c'est
marrant c'est mignon c'est à occuper les
faits c'est drôle merci de me regarder
cette vidéo
si tu aimes ce pays comme moi hésite pas
à mettre un coup du bruit et abonne toi
[Musique]
eh bien vous de cette vidéo de réaction
est une réaction envoyée moi qui rajic
ça m'a fait super marrer de voir des
gens regardez mes vidéos comme ça à voir
leurs réactions ou ce qu'ils pensaient
que c'était assez c'est toujours
enrichissant je trouve déjà parce que ça
fait des vues et donc ça enrichit au
sens propre
et ensuite et ensuite parce que ça
permet de vraiment se rendre compte de
ce que les gens pensent de soi et je
pense qu'il faut pas non plus trop se
focaliser là dessus et parce qu'ils
n'ont tu tombe facilement dans le bas je
vais faire que ce que les gens aiment et
je vais prendre zéro risque et je vais
même plus faire ce que moi j'aime j'ai
vraiment répondre parfaitement aux
attentes des gens et du coup en france
et a déjà tué surprend tous les genres
et en plus ce n'était pas nous y ait de
moins en moins mais là ça m'a fait du
bien bon apparemment ils connaissaient
déjà tous la chaîne youtube donc il
était il aimait plus ou moins mais je me
demande sur fédérer actions comme ça des
à des gens qui sont complètement
déconnectés tous à georges pas des
cinquantenaires des barèmes des
grands-parents quoi je pense qu'ils
répondraient tout à fait autre chose
serait alors dans le choc des
générations faible inflation a fait
perdre plaisir de près cette vidéo et
puis vos réactions ils sont rigolotes
donc là bas je veux vraiment pas la
faire sur nos vies en plus les réactions
dans la vidéo était pas dingue
franchement si c'est c'était cool
c'était vraiment cool
adieu projet de perceva regarder portez
vous bien géré
[Musique]
ça